in this video we are going to introduce
ourselves to the idea of permutations
which is a fancy word for a pretty
straightforward concept which is what
are the number of ways that we can
arrange things how many different
possibilities are there
and to make that a little bit tangible
let's
have an example with say a sofa my sofa
can seat exactly three people i have
seat number one on the left of the sofa
seat number two in the middle of the
sofa and seat number three on the right
of the sofa and let's say we're going to
have three people who are going to sit
in these three seats person a
person b
and person c
how many different ways can these three
people sit in these three seats
pause this video and see if you can
figure it out on your own
well there are several ways to approach
this one way is to just try to think
through all of the possibilities you
could do it systematically you could say
all right let's if i have person a in
seat number one
then i could have person b and seat
number two and person c and seat number
three
and i could think of another situation
if i have person a and seat number one i
could then swap b and c so i could look
like
that
and that's all of the situations all of
the permutations where i have a in seat
number one so now let's put someone else
in seat number one so now let's put b in
seat number one and i could put a in the
middle and c on the right
or i could put b in seat number one and
then swap a and c so c and then a
and then if i put c
in seat number one
well i could put a in the middle and b
on the right
or with c in seat number one i could put
b in the middle and a on the right and
these are actually all of the
permutations and you can see that there
are one two
three four five six now this wasn't too
bad and in general if you're thinking
about permutations of six things and or
three things in three spaces you can do
it by hand but it could get very
complicated if i said hey i have a
hundred seats and i have 100 people that
are going to sit in them how do i figure
it out mathematically
well the way that you would do it and
this is going to be a technique that you
can use for really any number of people
and any number of seats is to really
just build off of what we just did here
what we did here is we started with seat
number one and we said all right how
many different possibilities are
how many different people could sit and
seat number one assuming no one has sat
down before
well three different people could sit in
seat number one you can see it right
over here this is where a is sitting in
seat number one this is where b is
sitting in seat number one and this is
where c is sitting in seat number one
now for each of those three
possibilities how many people can sit in
seat number two
well we saw when a sits in seat number
one there's two different possibilities
for seat number two when b sits in seat
number one there's two different
possibilities for seat number two when c
sits in seat number one this is a tongue
twister there's two different
possibilities for seat number two
and so you're going to have two
different possibilities here another way
to think about it is one person has
already sat down here there's three
different ways of getting that and so
there's two people left who could sit in
the second seat and we saw that right
over here where we really
wrote out the permutations
and so how many different permutations
are there for seat number one and seat
number two well you would multiply for
each of these three you have two for
each of these three in seat number one
you have two in seat number two
and then what about seat number three
well if you know who's in seat number
one and seat number two there's only one
person who can be in seat number three
and another way to think about it if two
people have already sat down there's
only one person who could be in seat
number three and so mathematically what
we could do is just say three times two
times one and you might recognize the
mathematical operation factorial which
literally just means hey start with that
number and then keep multiplying it by
the numbers one less than that and then
one less than that all the way until you
get to one and this is three factorial
which is going to be equal to
six which is exactly what we got here
and to appreciate the power of this
let's extend our example
let's say that we have five seats one
two
three
four
five and we have five people person a b
c d and e how many different ways can
these five people sit in these five
seats pause this video and figure it out
well you might immediately say well
that's going to be 5 factorial which is
going to be equal to 5
times 4 times 3 times 2 times 1.
5 times 4 is 20. 20 times 3 is
60 and then 60 times 2 is 120 and then
120 times 1 is equal to 120 and once
again that makes a lot of sense there
was five different if no one's sat down
there's five different possibilities for
seat number one and then what for each
of those possibilities there's four
people who could sit in seat number two
and then for each of those twenty
possibilities in seat numbers one and
two well there's going to be three
people who could sit in seat number
three and for each of these 60
possibilities there's two people who can
sit in seat number four
and then once you know who's in the
first four seats you know who has to sit
in that fifth seat and that's where we
got that 120 from